as you might already know or you're
finding out through this video a new sat
a new sat is coming
and the first administration of that new
sct is going to be on march
2016.
so the first question you're probably
asking well does this apply to me and
simple rule of thumb is if you're if
you're going to need to apply to college
before march 2016 and so that's the
majority of the folks who are applying
in the fall of 2015 well then the new
sat is probably going to come a little
bit too late for you but if you're
applying for college after that so the
fall of 2016 you could probably use
either sat the new sat or the current
sat and for sure if you're applying for
college in the fall of 2017 2018 you're
probably going to focus on the usat so
applying let me write this so this most
likely will apply
to folks applying
applying
for college
fall
and after
and
after
so with that out of the way what what's
the whole point what what is different
about the new sat and i'll do another
video where i go into the details and i
look at some of the sample items and we
think about how they're different from
the current sat but at a very high level
the goal is to really just be more
aligned with what you learn in school
more
aligned
more aligned with school and things that
you need to know to be college ready so
this even includes the vocabulary the
old sat was or you could say the current
sat was famous for
some words that you might not use in
your everyday conversations or you might
not use in
even in in college while the new s.a.t
is going to be more aligned with that it
still helps to know vocabulary but
they're going to be vocabulary words
that you'll find using a lot in college
or in your later life so it's going to
be more aligned with what you learn in
school and at a very general level it's
going to be
simpler
and it's going to be simpler in terms of
the number of sections and we'll talk
about that a little bit you're going to
have more time per question in general
it's also going to be simpler in terms
of how you think about taking the test
the the old or the current sat you have
to think about okay if i guess on this
there's going to be a penalty for
guessing while on the new s.a.t while on
the new sct there's no penalty for
guessing so if you can answer it answer
it if you can rule out some
choices still answer it you should just
always try to answer questions so you
don't have to really think about the
gamesmanship of it you just answer
answer the questions so the next thing
you're probably thinking about well what
are the sections and how is it actually
going to be how is it actually going to
be scored so what i've pre-drawn right
over here and i hope you can read it the
writing is a little bit small is i'm
comparing the
the current slash old sat up up here so
this this line right over here
is the
depending on your point of view the
current slash old sat
the one that is sun setting going into
2016. your last chance to take this is
january 2016 and then this one is the
new one
so this right over here that is the new
sat that's the one that we are talking
about
so big picture you see that the current
sat you have three math sections two of
them are 25 minutes one of them is 20
minutes and stylus are going to be given
in this order in fact it's likely to be
all shuffled up while in the new sat you
have two math sections one of them is 25
minutes and one is longer it's 55
minutes but they only have those two
sections and as you can see here the
longer section you're allowed to use a
calculator and so you'll probably see
questions that may be helpful to use a
calculator and then the other one you
don't use a calculator and you see that
the time is let's see you're comparing
this is this is 70 this is 70 minutes
and 54 questions versus 80 minutes and
58 questions so on average you have a
little bit
you have more time per question
and then we can look here in the reading
once again you have three sections of
reading two 25 minute sections 120
minute sections now you have one 65
minute reading sections and once again
on average you have more time per
question in the new reading sections and
i just want to make it very clear it's
not necessarily going to be administered
in this order i'm just showing you so we
can kind of compare
reading to reading or math to math
then in the current sat you have the one
that you would take if you took it in
2015 you have two writing sections or
two i guess you could say non-essay
writing sections one is 25 minutes one
is 10 minutes and then you also have an
essay section that that helps form part
of your writing score while in the new
sat you have just a 35 minute writing
section and then the essay is optional
this little green thing right over here
this is the experimental section in the
current sat and there might be
experimental sections in the new sat as
well so this is kind of a comparison of
of things and kind of the big takeaways
are you have fewer sections here more
time on average per question and then
the essay is optional
so how was all of this going to be
scored
well in the current
in the current sat
let me write it over here
so let me write the current
sat or you can view it as the old sat if
you want to view it that way
current old sat and i'm going to compare
it to the new sat
to the new s.a.t
and the current one
math
is scored on a scale from 200 to 800 and
that's still going to be the case in the
new sat
math is going to be scored on a scale
from 200 to 800.
now on the current sat
you have a reading score
reading score based on these three
sections right over here that's going to
be scored from 200 to 800. now in the
new sat reading and writing is going to
be combined so reading
reading
plus writing
plus
writing
is going to give you a 200 to 800 points
of score so this is going to be i don't
write it in blue or orange so maybe i
write it in both or let me
let me i'll write it in
another color 200
to 800 points for this
and in the current or old sat you have
writing slash essay
as a separate section
writing slash
essay
and this also gave you 200 to 800 points
while in the new sat you just have the
essay section is separate from the
writing in terms of score
so you just have
you just have the essay and once again
this is optional this is an optional
thing
you have the essay which is optional
i'll write it again even though i wrote
it down here as well it's optional and
that's going to be scored from 2 to four
sorry two to eight points
two to eight points so what are the big
takeaways here well in the current sat
when people give you their sat score
they're gonna give you a score if you
add these up the lowest possible score
is going to be 200 plus 200 plus 200
which is going to be 600 and the highest
one is 2400 so it's on a 2400 point
scale that's the current old sat well
the new one well people are likely to
give their scores the lowest possible
score is 200 plus 200 which is going to
be 400 and the highest one is going to
be
1600 800 in math 800 in reading plus
writing and then people might have also
an optional essay score
that is as high as eight points so those
are the big takeaways hopefully that
helps you a little bit and in a future
video i'll look at the actual items and
think about how things have changed